perte de glace bonsoir macao c'est
presque du cinéma c'est en tout cas un
titre un nom de ville qui a nourri bien
des films à hollywood et kouakou double
c'est un disque beaucoup mieux parce que
j'ai bien ici peut travailler un peu
mais pau j'amuse beaucoup et ça c'est un
coup double prévient leur coup double
c'est précisément pour l'expliquer le
titre du film qui sort le 15 avril
prochain
c'est un film de nostalgie vous vous
retrouvez burt lancaster qui est un très
ancien complice
oui oui et l'économie et moi depuis 40
ans on a fait sexuelles ensemble
coup double c'est le septième firmes non
plus on a fait ok cette réforme semble
alors un coup double c'est l'histoire de
deux truands de bandits qui sortent de
prison
après 30 ans passés derrière les
barreaux et qui retrouve une vie qui a
bien changé où ils ont beaucoup de mal à
retrouver leur place
vous avez vous eu des buts non mais ces
tensions qui me plaît qui me plaît
beaucoup parce que j'aime beaucoup de
travailler avec vous l'anc est parce que
et coup double c'est peut-être le fait
que nous ferons
on sombre et comme ça c'est un peu
nostalgique pour nous mais à la fois
très très minces que son jeu tout alors
voir tout de suite un extrait donc de ce
film on vous retrouve avec burt
lancaster je sais pas quel extrait qui a
été choisi par georges de bégoux mais je
suppose qu'on vous y retrouve tous les
deux on voit tout de suite ce rapide
extrait on rediscute après battait avec
sa locomotive et on s'taille au mexique
pour prouver qu'on a des couilles ce
sera a été notre premier c'est l'échec
nos bons vieux on ne le fera pas un
point c'est tout
qu'est-ce que ses inspecteurs je crois
qu'on va voler ton train ça va pas la
tête
personne ne vole les trains de nos jours
je crois que tu as mal renseigné
bonhomme coutu était tout ce temps on
est venu ici pour papoter ou shourd
avait un train tout ce que tu voudras
j'ai envie de leur [ __ ] un peu la
trouille
alors tu viens si seulement je t'avais
utoya 30 ans tu n'as forteresse qu'elle
chante l'oreille
car de glace que pensez vous de votre
voix françaises
je crois que j'ai parfois c'est beaucoup
mieux dans le film vous avez vous
retrouvé votre voix c'est bien oui oui
très bien le faire je suis étonné je
crois que cette fête très bien faire
vous avez j'ai regardé votre
filmographie vous avez tourné 75 films
ou séries de télévision peu trop
peut-être
alors vous avez participé à tous les
grands moments du cinéma américain de ce
qu'on appelait à hollywood
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a dans les
jeunes comédiens les jeunes réalisateurs
excepté votre fils michael des
réalisateurs des comédiens qui vous qui
vous pleuvent qui vous impressionne vous
avez bien et les ans des parents
maintenant quand vous engagez mois qu'on
a travaillé ya des années on a fait
peut-être trois films chaque année
maintenant les gens ne fait pas beaucoup
de firmes peut-être en juin par an mais
je crois que il ya beaucoup de jeunes
qui arrivent avec beaucoup de talent
mais quand je voudrais que maintenant
quand je pose de quelqu'un je pense
seulement de monde mais qui a fait
beaucoup de succès avec ses films
notamment en france le diamant du nil vu
d'autres encore on vous connaît bien
comme comédien de film d'action c'est un
petit peu moins en france que vous avez
été longtemps vous êtes toujours ce
qu'on appelle un comédien engagé
vous êtes battre beaucoup battus contre
la liste noire de mccarthy vous avez
fait retravailler des réalisateurs qui
était interdit à l'époque qu'est ce que
vous pensez aujourd'hui deux de leurs de
tous ces films engagés sur par exemple
la guerre du vietnam et qui c'est qui
envahissent les écrans américains je
pense à platoon par exemple qui fait
beaucoup de problèmes aux états unis
quelle est votre appréciation de la tour
je crois que c'est un jeune très bien
faire sur la guerre du vietnam il fera
ce qu il n'y a pas beaucoup de films
comme ça d'habitude je crois le plus pas
d'affirmer sans taux trop jeune cette
menace il en faut 100 partout on aime
quand j'ai vu quand on répond c'est donc
ce que j'ai fait azg aurait commandé
s'enfoncèrent les sentiers de la gloire
avec stanley kubrick c'est ça oui c'est
une très engagé carglass merci le temps
et a peu compté merci et on ira donc
voir votre film qui sort donc le 15
avril est ce un film donc je vous
remercie c'est bien just can't you
réalisateur c'est cela gfk nos mairies
oui merci kirk